[Music]
hey guys welcome to off-the-record or we
talk about anything wrong I tell you
something this guy ran here I almost I
most didn't want to do it but as a
3-mile it's what it was supposed to be
about six-and-a-half but then because of
that mile detour it was about seven and
a half maybe one was eight why are you
changing your life all of a sudden well
I wasn't his dude named like David
Goggin and like David Goggin is like
we've you guys actually introduced me
them and so that's the only reason why I
clicked on that Joe Rogan podcast yeah
cuz I was like did ya you guys mentioned
David Collins to me and it was like this
video where it was like exactly you guys
found him a while ago and I did I sent
it to David to talk [ __ ] some yeah
that's probably something like that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then I clicked on it
and then you listen to this guy's life
story and it's pretty cool
now it's very random that some random
dude can actually like speak to you very
well yeah it's never happened to me
before because usually I'll listen to a
podcast and it'll just be like cool you
know I mean but there was nothing about
the way this guy spoke that made me go
back to it I have a crush on him a
little bit so he he basically spoke in
this way that I think it was really cool
and it kind of spoke to me because I
related to related to it a lot it's like
and he spoke one thing that kind of
really stuck out was his one thing he
says a lot of people are motivated but
they're not determined those are two
really big different was the difference
so he says like motivated is this like
you watched the Rocky movie right you
see rocky go in he goes back in the ring
gets his ass beat gets knocked out you
wake up and you're like today this is
what I'm gonna do it starts raining
outside you go tomorrow I'll do it next
time I'm still motivated though that's
the difference determine is when you
look at that rain and you say you know
what it doesn't matter if it's raining
I'm still gonna do it so that's how I
felt like I was always motivated but I
was never determined and so like I think
like he spoke to he speaks to the
average person but he does amazing
things and that's the difference between
a lot of people these people who are
amazing they only tell you that you're
weak but they don't tell you that you're
them so he doesn't the other way around
so he knows how to speak to people who
are on who are average and so for me I'm
like okay remember that remember I was
walking like three miles and then the
day it rained after and I was gonna
knock I was not gonna do the the
three-mile walkers raining because it
was raining and then I listened to
Podcast again and I heard that
motivation determination part got up and
I did it anyways and so it's like when
you run on the rained all the Instagram
video comes out way more epic especially
slow hey if you were really determined
you could do without listening to the
podcast absolutely not I still believe
that and the cool thing is - he goes
like you know you don't have to be me
I'm not telling you you have to be a
Navy SEAL you don't have to do hell week
three times you can't even go that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying is like
you you are your own person and the
thing is it's like you just got to
defeat your own inner demons and that's
about it you got to climb your own
Everest
I gotta this really what it is yeah you
know and it's so funny like when you
look at a guy who's 300 pounds
he failed becoming a Navy City he fails
becoming a Navy SEAL he has two holes in
his heart you know his father was a pimp
his mom was abused he was called stupid
he read at a fourth-grade reading level
when he was in high school could it pass
the [ __ ] as bad as that was for
idiots you should hear
he couldn't [ __ ] pass it anything
events is bad oh then he also went to
Ranger School thing so that's crazy
back into that and it's a pretty cool
story it's been going on for this is
week three so it's uh it's pretty good
when girls hear stuff like this does it
motivate you or inspire you guys the
same way
Oh like David boggans yeah yeah like
putting like I feel like for guys like
when we hear stuff like this and
especially if they speak our language
like David Goggin speaks way definitely
it didn't like some hardcore head
banging type of dude you know like that
they're just like a meathead they ever
Goggins explains things when like in a
very grounded relatable way so when I
listen to - I'm just all fungus guy
pumps me up it makes me like wanna do
triple what I like it makes me feel like
whatever goals I set are way too low
when you guys like hear stories like
this or if you listen to them do you
guys go like no we're girls we just want
to make up and brush our hairs
the stories I know yeah I read a lot of
personal development books and I feel
like it's the same kind of jam like
Eckhart Tolle it gets me in that
spiritual like world and then like Tony
Robbins is like really like oh like he
says [ __ ] and then he like makes me want
to do things and then and then I don't
know that like even the old ones like
Malcolm Gladwell and like I had win
friends and influence people like even
all those old books magical thinking big
is a really good one where you're like
oh my goals are here and then you read
that book and you're like oh [ __ ] that's
way so that's way too low like it should
be up here I think I'm pretty determined
though as a person I I like what I
realized though the common denominator
for all those things none of them are
physical physical based they're all
motivation or emotional yeah I guess
it's what you prioritize cuz like for me
I don't think I mean I I work out I have
goals and working out I want to you know
be healthy as healthy as I can go
mystically fit as that can be but I
don't think of it as a like oh I've
reached a success point went with
physical stuff it's more and like career
stuff so like I felt like I was failing
a lot a lot of people feel like they're
failing during the life and then I read
Lucille Ball's out of her biography and
she like tried to be an actress when she
was 15 she failed three times in high
school couldn't get into the acting
school that she wanted to get into she
was told she would countless would never
make it she had to do like extra work
basically until she like started
modeling and then she got discovered on
the EDD what's that all over Oh ed
sullivan show yeah and she was one of
like the dancer girls or whatever and
then she got these little bit rolls all
through her 30s she was just getting
tiny little roll and then yeah
vaudeville with well her and Desi like
came up with this show where as like a
Cuban guy and a white girl living
together as husband and wife and they
pitched it to CBS and CBS was like no no
one would ever go for that that's
terrible like that's not relatable and
so they made it themselves and then they
did a vaudeville thing or with that did
loose
desi show basically basically I Love
Lucy on Bob Dylan was huge hit and then
they went back and produced the pilot
themselves and then became a hit and she
became the first woman multi-millionaire
in history first yeah and she even
bought out dezzy's half of the company
so she owned she owned all of her own
[ __ ] but by that time she was like in
her 40s and so like every time I feel
like I'm feeling and entertainment or
comedy or whatever someone says like I'm
not funny enough or I'm not talented
acting or whatever I just think of like
she's you're as brave she is and like
without that in mind I think you just
need that like mental picture somebody
that's like you that did it that's the
cool thing about like I mean her story
is just similar to like David Goggins
you know you see like they're like New
Year's in yeah they failed a bunch yeah
and the thing about it that I really
like about some of my Lucille Ball or
David Coggins it's not theory you know I
mean so people always talk about Theory
you know there's a lot of you [ __ ]
youtubers out there and I'd like to talk
this talk would you want to be a
motivational speaker and you want to
write autobiographies at the age of 20
when you have a [ __ ] live life that's
why you can't how can you talk [ __ ] with
you memoirs memoirs that 20-year go [ __ ]
yourself first of all you haven't lived
[ __ ] so you how can you say that and
motivate people you have to do it
yourself first before you get to tell
somebody what to do with their life and
that's that's like a huge problem that a
lot of people have I think nowadays and
so I read David Goss you hear Lucille
Ball story that's what it is they lived
it yeah then it makes Bennett really
motivates you couldn't feel the truth
and you when you hear yeah and I think
we live in a society where we just want
to speak more than do you don't want to
hear stories from someone that never got
buffa before yes all right
because if someone gets to know the more
that someone gets butt-fucked by life
you're like [ __ ] this one's been through
a lot don't buy life like listening to
all porn stars because then it eradicate
Saul your own excuses yeah she's not
buck by 20 times yeah
you're like oh well I can't do it
because blah and then you lose he's like
well I did that 50 times I was like oh
[ __ ] I tried seven times like it's crazy
bro she was getting molested by her
uncle and she was like but yeah grasp or
yeah that's really bad yeah motivate
yeah yeah so yeah it's just kind of like
one of those things like you just like
your own hero that you can hold it and
be like every time you feel yourself
slipping you're like oh they did it I
have a lot of those for a lot of
different areas in my life yeah all
looks you like stunt women and those
like in particular like they're the ones
that like motivate me like crazy someone
that's so interesting I know it's so
weird what am i got to take a beating
because they look really hot right cuz
they're in a movie or whatever but then
they're doing like amazing stunts and
stuff and I'm like [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
amazing I want to do that um and then I
look to like different like I listen to
a lot of different podcasts like of
business building and I'm just like oh
[ __ ] yeah a lot of the stuff that we're
going through they've gone through it
and they're like multi-million dollar
companies there's just different areas
of my life I like latch on to different
people that I can relate to this is hard
because like I think people give up at
that forty percent mark you know I mean
so it's like you're still going through
everything but that the forty percent
you or anything your end of your rope
yeah there's still 60 percent more to go
but then all you see is that that forty
percent is the end there's also a rule
the 90/10 rule have you heard of that
rule where ten percent of the stuff gets
done in ninety percent of the time and
then 90 percent of your goals get done
in the last ten percent of time so it's
like because like a build a compounding
effect and and like you're saying like
if you give up at 85 percent you haven't
even hit where the majority of the goals
are gonna come from so and then there's
I guess it like repeats itself
throughout different things like the 90%
of your money is made from ten of the
10% of the stuff you do it applies to
just like a lot of things yeah there's
another one called the 80/20 rule it's
probably the same concept
but most of your effective and and most
of your you know income or whatever is
done by 20% of your effort yeah same
with probably like 20% of your workout
is producing 80% of the results but also
it's the same thing for negativity so
what is your 20% of problems that are
causing you 80% of your inconveniences
or whatever in life and if you sit down
and look at it your 20% that's that's a
lot of people's it's it's their it's
their significant other
we're like most people will be like I
don't have any problems with anyone
except for the person I'm with or
whatever
oh that joke at uber you know nobody
it's it applies like the 90/10 rule or
whatever that that that math applies in
a lot of different things yeah dude we
need to make a [ __ ] ebook would you
guys be interested in a [ __ ] eBook
what kind of a buy haven't been Buffett
enough you gotta stop saying it like
that you can't say you're gonna have a
hundreds of people showing up at your
door ready to but [ __ ] at you would
you get mad if I wanna go skydiving why
would I ever get mad I've been pushing
you to do crazy to have a kid no that
could risk dying it's a selfish move no
uh no I think it's fine it's done so
like if you were like I'm gonna do
something that no one's ever done before
for like the first time ever I'd be like
whoa you might want to slow your roll
that other people do it first what other
people diverse doctor there's no David
Goggin and how he's like whatever makes
you comfortable or uncomfortable you
have to do it the more you hate
something the more you have to do it
because when you stay in your comfort
zone yeah you don't ever you don't ever
learn anything about yourself all you're
doing is being the yes-man to yourself
so that's just comfortable yes yes yes
you're so awesome I'm looking myself in
the mirror but that's not really who you
are you find out who you are in an
uncomfortable space so after listening
to my man I should face my fears
so what's your fear then what's your
challenge itself out what if I die in
Thai doesn't have a dad oh I give up I
give up my mom you're her 20% of
problems anyway got my motorcycle dreams
for taiko so you go back about
motorcycle no we just slow down you're
don't roll too risky that's not
something you fear that's something that
you think is cool be honest with
yourself
no but what are the motorcycles I gave
it up cause like I don't want to risk go
to jail then cuz I fear going to jail I
should change College myself it's a cool
thing like for example when you see all
these people that surpass adversity and
then they get to their goals and their
dreams come true like like when we watch
the Oscars a lot of people that are
winning Oscars for the first time in
their lives and it's such a huge
accomplishment that's so motivating yeah
you know what the huge misconception is
though I think people think that there's
a linear trajectory or like an upward
like this your goal but in the reality
is it's like this anybody hit this and
go right back now yeah you might never
even hit this you go here and you hit
something else that's like you're like
oh [ __ ] this is actually pretty small
and this is way better yeah yeah I mean
and it doesn't stop when you win the
Oscar does this stop when you it's just
life is constantly full of just [ __ ]
and I think once you get past that and
understand that it's just gonna have ups
and downs regardless it's gonna be
constantly challenging and when one
thing becomes the standard that's gonna
be boring like if 10 miles was already
enough but once you achieve that 10 mile
goal of jogging now it's too boring
after three years of running 10 miles
yeah you got to go 100 miles you got to
keep pushing it and that's actually the
fun part the journey yeah it's like this
concept of like that I think that I I
don't do that I I don't know where it
happened before cuz it was like this
before when I was younger but then I
think like it's like he said like you
reach a certain goal and if you don't
push past that goal you just start being
very upset you know you've become very
empty you know what I mean and so like
that's why I like that concept or even
David Goggin says it's kind of what I
what I kind of already do right now but
he just reinforced it was triple Downing
on your weaknesses I'm acting this year
I actually don't like acting
I mean but I'm not gonna know if I
dislike it until I try it so that's why
this year I'm trying acting maybe next
year I won't but I'm not gonna know if I
like it if I just by speculating that's
that's one of those things that I think
it's like you're scared of it like it's
uncomfortable and like you'd rather be
like oh I don't like acting then no then
face your fears of like maybe not being
good at it or whatever you're scared
about it or not not liking it or hating
it or whatever it is you'd rather just
be like I just know I don't like it that
I think that's more of like a facing
your fear type of uncomfortable thing
yeah which is really cool too because
like I think that like it happens in a
lot of things like like when people at
the gym and they just do the same
circuit training over and over again and
they never like show any progress that
but they're like just doing the same
thing over and over again you never get
anywhere or as if they just like pushed
and did like something different like
they could start yeah and like the cool
thing is that I think like a lot of
people forget to it's like inserting
like the whole difficulty time whatever
it's bad here what's on the other side
of accomplishment it feels ten times
better than what was over here yeah you
know what I mean so whatever you're
going through right now by the time you
reach this all this [ __ ] is gonna start
to make sense yeah you know even you
that will become your comfortable place
like you'll start to thrive for it and
then you'll start thirsting for some
type of novel weird challenging
experience yeah yeah like kind of like
how I'm doing this right now it's I so
number one like I have an inguinal
hernia I can't lift weights so this is
like the most difficult time I've ever
had losing weight losing weight it's
because I can't lift weights
so I'm actually eliminating a huge part
of my workout that I'm so comfortable
doing which is why I'm running now I
don't run so I'm saying like I [ __ ]
hate running I don't have a choice so
it's like I could say like oh I have a
hernia I could chill out you know I also
my back is also [ __ ] up but I've
always used like these small little
vices excuses for why I don't work out
but at the end of the day like I'm still
here then you don't learn to love it
though I used to hate running
yeah I kept doing it and doing it and I
started feeling comfortable after the
runner's high and I love the runners
like it's so rewarding I started to like
walk
like for sure walking is like something
I have to start my day with now which I
didn't think it would happen like in two
weeks
but it's definitely like a part of me
like the first thing I do before I do
anything else is I want hmm guess my day
started and it has to be at least three
miles because I'm not gonna go backwards
do you find too that I finally when I
every year I feel like I find a new
hobby that I become obsessed with like
something that I've never done before
something I've never learned before but
like putting yourself in that like
beginner's mind oh yeah yeah you're
allowed to fail because like you're just
you're just learning this it kind of
gives you like a new high a new rush
where like now you're more motivated in
the other areas of your life well that
you were already doing before like
because I started doing watercolor this
year like last year it was cooking here
before that it was like jewelry making
whatever but whenever like I pick up
something new and I start like making
something I've never made before I start
getting more creative in like writing
and acting and all the stuff that I
already do that I maybe plateaued at
before yeah forgot where I read draw
parallels now like making a basket or a
clay sculpture like that creative
expression you start drawing parallels
with the theme that yeah you know the
creator of off-white Virgil okay I've
heard of the brand off white it's like a
big Street where Brad
okay well it's huge so basically when he
was going to fashion school he also
before you've been doing that he went to
he wanted to be an architect but he went
to architecture school and then his
teacher was kind of like talking down to
a lot of their students and they're like
well if you can't make this class like
you're not gonna make it anywhere and
then Virgil he was just like what like
why would you say something like that
and then he's like well you're so smug
like what why are you so confident he's
like well actually like I don't even
want to be an architect like because I
know whatever I'm gonna learn here I'm
gonna apply when I do fashion he's like
because because of those parallels yeah
and I'm just like that [ __ ] sick that
someone like you know was able to see
that and he's like well I just want to
do ARCIC I just want to learn how like a
structure is made because I'm gonna
apply that to my clothing right now he
has like one of the biggest street wear
brands out that's so cool like even when
you said remember I forgot what you said
but it was like somebody mentioned to
you or it was a person that said there's
an importance to why you wake up in the
morning and you make your bed
first thing a lot of a lot of military
people stress that so much yeah yeah
there's like an accomplishment in the
beginning there's like a parallel to how
you that has like a snowball effect with
the rest of your day yeah just like I'll
wake up and take a [ __ ] yeah your eyes
is red go like that I need a cup of
coffee first I do a bottle water okay
yeah a bottle water was there has to be
something that pushes it yeah which I
didn't do this more that's why I had to
take a [ __ ] on the way when after the
first mile and luckily those are
pavilions that's the word I just read in
oh God thank you Jesus that's when you
run the fastest you're tired and you're
like a turtle head cook yeah it was
funny because I was right in the middle
say there's a bonds and a pavilions just
I clean like I we start on goals and
with [ __ ]
[Music]